well today we finally got all the dets
of the details wait the details of the
details of the graphics cards you all
have been waiting to hear about since
CES you know the the the one that
everyone was briefed on and then during
the keynote just decided to say what
graphics cards what are you talking
about so finally we have some of the
details not quite all of the details
regarding the 9000 Series graphics cards
coming out from AMD specifically the
9070 and 9070 XT so let's see if AMD
continues its tradition of never missing
an opportunity to miss an
opportunity Jaa is the number one online
gaming Marketplace to buy and sell new
and used gaming gear and get awesome
custom PCS at amazing prices Java's
mission is to be the community where
great gaming gear is sold at reasonable
prices by putting the market in the
hands of Gamers by building the best
place for you to discuss buy and sell
your PC gear Java is also proud of their
GPU and CPU buying program where Jaba
will make you a direct offer on your
used CPUs and gpus to help immediately
offset the cost of your new hardware
simply click cck on the get an offer
button and see an instant offer on your
components Java's buyer and seller
protection policies ensure safe and
reliable transactions while verified
sellers offer an increased buying
experience through prev vetted sellers
so you can shop with peace of mind to
get started browsing amazing deals and
to see all that Jawa has to offer from
enthusiasts just like you follow the
sponsored Link in the description below
there's a lot of the press deck that
we're just going to skip and not care
about like for instance all the AI
performance stuff we don't we're not AI
developers we don't use AI in any way
that doesn't mean anything uh to us
around here whatsoever um I will tell
you tell you this though this is
obviously the rdna dna4 architecture
there's new there's gen 3 R tracing
cores um they're boasting the in
increased performance per dollar value
performance for dollar performance per
value value wow I am really just I'm
ready for the weekend all right anyway
moving on not going to do an
architecture Deep dive because I'll be
honest I I just am not that versed in
the uh engineering side of these gpus
and the dies I'll tell what I'm like
most of you where I just care about
Dollar in and performance out what does
that look like and I think that's what
most people care about I don't think
most people care about how the sausage
is made they just care about the
sausage okay so just on a uh on a on a
quick note though at least regarding the
AI accelerators if you are one of those
people that care about that they're
boasting floating Point 16 a 2X
Improvement uh integer 8 a 4X
improvement fp16 with SP sparsity 4X and
integer 8 visarity 8X and floating Point
8 formats new that's what it says it
says new so whatever that means all
right moving on um you know what's funny
they they don't have a reference card
this time around I put the the last two
reference cards up here because they
look so good I've actually loved amd's
design uh Team when it comes to
designing these cards and the renders
that we can see right here of what a
reference card would have looked like is
amazing but they don't they're not
making them so all of the reviews going
forward are going to be third party
cards so obviously like Sapphire XFX
power color you know the The Usual
Suspects when it comes to the uh the AMD
cards so that's a little bit unfortunate
let's go and talk about price real quick
I know that's the thing people are most
interested in and like Steve's video
that went up the other day saying hey
don't screw this up again it should be
don't screw this up quotes again so the
the competitors we have not even talking
about Nvidia talking about their own
uplift and their own performance uh and
price opportunity here compared to the
7900 XTX it was $9.99 at launch the 7900
XT was $ 8.99 at launch and the 7900 GRE
which ended up being a worldwide release
although it was a GPU that was designed
specifically for the Chinese market was
$549 now the 7900 GRE is still one of
the most relevant price to Performance
like propositions that exist
unfortunately the GRE is like long gone
like the GRE hellhound amazing amazing
card it
it it was great actually it was a skew
that AMD should have just made from the
get-go to be honest um anyway when they
talk about this the slotting of pricing
here they're using the architecture and
the uh the the core counts and such to
justify the pricing so for instance at
$1,000 they had 96 rna3 cus 57.8 billion
transistors $100 less at9 or $900 the
7900 XT had 84 rdna 3 cus and 55 5.8
billion
transistors and then down at the 550
range at the 7900 GRE price 80 rdna 3 uh
3 cus and
53.8 billion
transistors so you can see right here
and and they also show like The
Resolution that the cards are sort of
aimed at so the 7900 XT and XTX are
aimed at 4K gaming and the 7900 gr was
pointed at 1440p gaming although let's
be real it was very capable of being a
4K Gam card now the RX 9070 series as
you can see slots between both of those
7,000 Series brackets so above the 700
7900 gr and below the 7900 xt/ XTX um
and that's because obviously there's two
skews there so it shows up to 64 rdna 4
cus that's going to be for the XT and up
to 53.9 billion transistors once again
that's going to be for the XT so when it
says up to just know they're referring
to the XT those are the only two skes to
deal with here so in terms of pricing
this is this is why we are all just
holding our breath wondering what the
hell the price is going to be and here's
the fun fact they don't know yet cuz if
they knew it would be right here on the
slide we know it's going to be more than
$549 and less than $8.99 that is all we
know because that is where they slotted
it on this chart it's a little odd to me
that we are this close to the launch and
they have not set the price yet it
doesn't help that leaked uh like
pre-order links and stuff for like
Amazon and a couple other websites in
Canada showed like pricing that ended up
being right around 850
USD so your guess is as good as mine now
the problem is because they're only
going to be third party cards the price
ranges are going to vary greatly
depending on the design you're going to
have your more basic designs and then
you're going to have your big beefy
overclocking quote unquote designs I say
quote unquote cuz the AMD cards they're
interesting when it comes to
overclocking usually just because the
way the architecture works and it's more
tilis design but we got a huge range
here so if you're just here for the
price I'm sorry we don't know it either
in fact the fact that AMD was reaching
out to influencers to ask what do you
think the price should be and any answer
other than as how cheap can you make it
is the wrong answer so you should never
give a dollar amount when when a brand
asks you what should we price it at you
should literally always respond what is
the absolute cheapest you can price it
at that's the answer answer that's how
you go consumer friendly especially in
today's landscape of or environment
regarding pricing okay so here's the
specs that we know the RX 9070 has 56
compute units versus 64 on the XT we
just saw that in the previous chart 56
Hardware RT accelerators versus
64 uh 112 AI accelerators which I guess
unless they start really getting
leveraged in games and I guess this
would help when it comes to like hyper
RX and stuff like that which is like
amd's kind of version of optimization of
upscaling plus a AI uh frame gen so the
more AI accelerators you have really
helps out the hyper RX stuff when it
comes to AMD uh versus 128 found in the
9070 XT now speeds Peak AI tops 1,165
versus
1,557 boost clocks big discrepancy in
the Boost clocks here 2.52 GHz boost on
the 970 versus 2.97 on the 970 XT so we
are talking
four over 400 about 450 MHz of clock
difference here that's obviously going
to vary by the model though because
every single one of the the addin board
partners are going to have their own
sauce and formula built into their bios
so I'm going to assume they're going to
all hit at least these numbers that's
the way I'm looking at it if they are
not hitting at least these numbers
something is wrong uh it is a pcie gen
5x16 device but as we've already tested
even with the 5090 it really makes no
difference even all the way down to PCI
G 3x 16 giving us like 3% to 4%
difference when going from Gen 5 to gen
3 so I wouldn't put two much uh
investment into the idea of it being a
pci5 device being all that exciting okay
so let's go ahead and talk about the
9070 first that might end up being one
of the best value propositions and gpus
that we can possibly consider right now
I would assume the performance is
targeting right at the uh RTX uh
570 which is why they named it that way
in fact the one thing they did say back
in January was that they named it this
so that you had a better performance
parody with naming so you can understand
what sort of slots in with Nvidia I
don't really like that cuz that sounds
too much like you're just following suit
rather than trying to be your
own your own entity if you will so
whatever anyway versus the 6800 XT uh
now they they do a lot of comparison
between a more than a generation old
like two gen Stu old same thing when
they talk about versus Nvidia they're
comparing it to like 30 series cards and
I think the reason for that is a lot of
people do tend to skip Generations
whenever they do their updates so
whenever you a lot of people when they
upgrade they don't do a nextg upgrade
they tend to wait a generation and leap
frogs so they're skipping a gen every
time so this would be very relevant
because a lot of these cards are going
on 5 years plus old which makes them uh
well the performance gains pretty big
when you compare previous gen versus
previous two gens anyway compared to the
6800 XT which was $100 more than 970 uh
it is a 38% uplift in performance across
30 titles so that's the medium uh or the
mean uplift versus RTX 3080 which was a
$700 card at 4K Max settings it's 26%
faster in gaming don't forget this is
the 9070 not the
XT so when they compare it to the GRE
though which is a previous gen card it's
21% faster mean average across 30 titles
some are going to have very little
uplift like f124 only had 5% Assassin's
Creed Mirage had 128 uh% or 28% total uh
uplift over the GRE so depending on the
ver the graphics card that you're coming
from uh I don't know if anyone with a
7900 GRE should necessarily run out and
buy this card although let's just let's
just throw a hypothetical out there with
the way graphics
cards are priced today even the used
Market a $550
GRE would bring at least $550 today
mostly because of the fact that you
really can't buy them new anymore
they're very difficult to find so I
think if you were to price it at 550
you'd be able to sell it now if you can
get your hands on a
9070 that's the that's the other end of
the equation we've heard this from AMD
before and I my when I when they said
this to me on the phone my exact
response was don't be so confident
because their response was oh we're
going to have plenty of inventory we're
going to have plenty like we expect a we
expect plenty of availability on launch
day and my exact response was don't be
so confident these are different times I
have a feeling that these will still
sell out and you want to know why if you
live near a Micro Center just take a
trip and look at the GPU aisle it's rare
to see the Nvidia aisle picked clean and
the AMD aisle picked clean and if
anything
Nvidia some of the best marketing for
AMD right now is all of the Nvidia
crappy that's happening around 50 Series
I don't think we've ever had a launch
that's pushed people the other direction
than we have this time regarding Nvidia
so that's why we say don't screw this up
because this you literally have been
handed a royal flush but don't be the
guy that got dealt a royal flush and
you're like I'm going to put two cards
back cuz AMD has done that in the past
more than
once okay moving on now obviously we
care about the 9070
XT no idea what that price is going to
be I still think we're looking at this
being in the 700s to potentially I I
think
we my prediction here if
AMD is looking at this as maybe we make
sure we cover our cost now that's not
covering your cost is not a good
business model that that is not a good
business model you will not be in
business long if you only operate to
cover your
costs if you can cover your
costs this generation and price it to
gain some market share because market
share is what gives people confidence to
buy
something yeah you might you might
not take a bath you also might not make
a lot of profit this time you're after
market share just like the CPU Market
with ryzen back in 2016 and look at how
that's gone for them in the last 10
years take back market share make the
pricing
aggressive I say $6.49 is what the 97 XT
should be and I think 549 is what the
970 should be to really go after that
7900 gr replacement it's also important
to note that influencers may or may not
have already had these cards for a
little while I can neither confirm nor
deny so it's weird that we that people
are getting the deck after the card so
this is an interesting perspective for
some people on seeing this information
after having already potentially maybe
played with it so anyway on their charts
moving forward they're comparing the 970
XT to the 6900 XT uh that's a 51% faster
gaming uh mean average across 30 titles
uh versus RTX 390 which had a
$1,499 MSRP and 4K Max settings showing
26% faster than the 3090 across 30 games
uh also the 600 XT was a grand so it is
looking uh if you if you're on a 3090
and you paid that kind of price for it
which doesn't feel like that long ago it
kind of sucks when mid-range cards like
this although this is this is upper
mid-range uh comes out and just Stomps
all over your card that's when fomo
really starts to happen and kick in
anyway compared to the 7900 GR in 4k uh
looks like we're seeing a range of
anywhere between 23% to 48% faster in
Native 4K I love they're showing native
4k on here because Nvidia didn't do a
lot of that in the 50 Series which is
what gave all the ammunition for the
fake frames fake frames fake frames and
yes guess what AMD has fake frames too
hello hyper
RX anyway moving on I love that these
charts are in Native 4K cuz this is just
showing the generational horsepower
uplift they're not heavily leaning into
software uplift they do that later in
the chch uh anyway and in rate tracing
performance versus the 7900 GRE anywhere
between 36% uplift to 66% uplift across
the board that is
massive uh anyway in 1440p 38% mean
average across 30 titles ranging 23% to
44% and in RT 34% to 68% so it's looking
really really strong now we'll talk
about the hyper RX stuff real quick
because it is something worth noting
there's a lot of people Phil included
that do turn on frame gen depending on
the title depending how hard it is to
run and depending on the settings Phil
loves the eye candy and he will turn all
that stuff on and move into frame gen uh
to be able to get the fps to a smooth
frame rate now yes there is input
latency uh Nvidia has the uh Nvidia
reflex obviously AMD has anti-ag which
is designed to reduce the amount of
input input latency um still a lot to be
heard about their AMD fluid motion
frames 2.1 it just says more coming soon
I assume maybe it's not really ready to
be talked about necessarily yet but
hyper RX as I said which turns on a
suite of features it's not just a
feature like frame gen when you turn on
hyper RX which is a suite of features
including anti-ag and FSR um and frame
gen you're seeing uplifts of 2.8x 2.6x
2.9x specifically in certain titles um
which makes a whole lot of sense there's
no mentioning here of quote unquote
multiframe gen that's a hardware thing
found on Nvidia cards it's important to
also note that hyper RX and uh frame gen
on AMD are done at a driver level not at
a hardware level so that's how they were
able to actually give this level of
improvement going all the way back to
the 6000 series cards it's not like or
Nvidia they kind of put it behind a pay
wall where oh it's Hardware related so
if you are running anything older than
certain Hardware you don't get these new
features now Nvidia did actually uh open
dss4 up to all the way back to 20 series
as long as you had tensor cores in your
GPU to get these sharper models um
obviously multiframe gen though was a
hardware thing locked behind the uh
blackw architecture so AMD doing on a
driver level though these improvements
we're seeing here uh actually do go back
to the 6000 series cards okay now one
thing to talk about here when it comes
to uh fs4 or FSR 4 though this is going
to be specifically uh 9000 Series it
looks like cuz they are utilizing ml uh
powered upscaling so that is going to be
their AI cores that are inside the GPU
so although we don't personally care
about AI performance when it comes to
like AI workloads that is utilized in
games and such so this is where I talked
about here the you know the upscaler we
talked about the frame gen and all that
as being part of hyperarc Suite um that
is going to be specifically 9,000 Series
gpus um but anyway they they talk about
certain titles here they're going to be
utilizing the upgradeable FSR 3.1 API so
there's Ratchet and Clank you got
Spider-Man um Horizon zero Dawn uh Space
Marine 2 oh both Horizons actually Black
Ops 6 so they're showing a little demo
here in Space Marine where by turning on
hyper RX you went from 53 average FPS in
4k native to 102 182 FPS in 4k AMD FSR 4
so 3.4 times uplift again that kind of
stuff only matters to people that uh
want to get the highest frame rates but
also get the best eye candy now although
they're not using you know the same AI
modeling that Nvidia is they're call
obviously that's dlss um they're showing
some pretty solid improvements here in
the Fidelity one of the biggest issues
with FSR for the longest time was they
definitely were more blurry more smudgy
and they felt very far behind nvidia's
dlss models um but now if you look here
uh when they show this zoom in of these
towers way out in the distance here in
Space Marine 2 you can see the
comparison between 4K native FSR 3.1 and
FSR 4 and in my opinion it's very
difficult to tell the difference between
FSR 4 um and Native now if you look at
the little spires kind of sticking up in
the sky you can see FSR 3.1 they kind of
get lost like they sort of disappear and
look like they go dotted uh but if fs4
it stays solid same thing with the
antenna sticking out the side of the
building you can see in
3.1 um they have like some like smudging
they almost look like they're stretching
out but in FSR 4 they look uh very Tac
sharp uh close to Native 4K but
still small objects way out in the
distance are going to have some of these
artifacts but the artifacts are
improving so it's nice to see that
they're kind of staying on track with
improving the modeling uh cuz the number
one reason why people turn off FSR is it
just doesn't look great in certain
titles out in the distance now at launch
they're going to have 30 titles that are
supported with 75 plus coming throughout
the year I'm only mentioning this for
those that care about it um like I said
we have very differing opinions here in
our own office like Phil turns all this
stuff on I run native only so that it's
nice to see that that's all going to be
supported now because hyper RX is a
driver-based um technology there's going
to be there's thousands of games
supported uh here in 2025 but 30 games
for FSR 4 and then um in-game Fidelity
FX super resolution 2 and 3 have over
400 games supported now so it's nice to
see that happening then they move into a
lot of features here that uh personally
I'm not that interested in because it's
all talking about AI suite and
such I'm cautiously optimistic but I've
seen this movie before and I've seen all
the alternate endings for the love of
God it comes down to the price it
doesn't matter how good it performs if
the price is wrong I don't know what it
cost for them to make these cards I
don't I know times have changed I know
that tsmc is charging way more for their
silicon and their Wafers than they ever
have in the past I know that tsmc is the
largest Fab in the world supporting the
most customers out of any manufacturer
in the world I know that tsmc controls a
lot of the pricing here I I also know
that it's got to make some money or they
cannot continue to develop by them I
mean AMD in this instance my Rec my
recommendation I think what I think
customers would like to see I don't I I
don't know what the as low as you can
possibly make it is cuz I don't know I
don't have the details and know what it
cost to make them but I I firmly believe
the 970 should be
$5.49 I think it should be priced parody
with the 5070 or if you want to really
try to undercut them maybe $529 maybe we
don't have to do $50 increments but I
personally think anywhere between $5.99
to $6.49 for the 970 XT would be a
dramatic impact to what the 5070 and
5070 TI uh pricing looks like versus its
performance that some of us may or may
not have already seen so for the love of
God
AMD how many opportunities do you have
to be given before you get it right not
many people get this many
Mulligans
please get it on the green it's a golf
reference